les terroristes entre groupés dans le
bâtiment mais à l'intérieur de
l'appartement un des athlètes est alerté
par les bruits dans le couloir mochi va
une Berg un des sportifs cherche à se
rebeller avant d'être atteint par une
balle au visage dans une chambre les
assaillants ont donc réunis 10 sportifs
israéliens dont un est déjà mort
pour moi c'est une date qui a changé le
monde
[Applaudissements]
les Jeux Olympiques disparaissaient sous
la prise d'otage
c'est une image qui m'a hantée pendant
des années
personne n'était prêt pour cet événement
terrible
[Musique]
comment négocier face à des terroristes
sans en avoir jamais fait l'expérience
voici le cas d'une prise d'otage qui a
marqué l'Histoire celle de la délégation
israélienne aux Jeux Olympiques de
Munich en 1972
[Musique]
c'était comme au théâtre on voyait des
gens sur scène sans vraiment réaliser
que c'était la réalité
nous devions nous tenir prêt
afin de lancer la taxe
[Musique]
force de l'ordre membres du raid et du
GIGN famille et témoins il livre les
dessous de cette incroyable prise
d'otage
une diversion qui déclenche l'opération
et la vitesse d'exécution
et la garantie de libération des otages
c'était la préparation la plus totale
sincèrement les Allemands en bricoler
tout ce qui pouvait tourner mal à mal
tourner
comment les négociateurs ont-ils géré
cette crise à la résolution
catastrophique pour y répondre Marouane
Mery et Laurent Combalbert de
négociateurs professionnels la
difficulté sur Monique c'est qu'on a
agrégé le rôle de négociateur et des
décideurs et son prêt à repousser
l'ultimatum parce qu'il bénéficie d'une
couverture médiatique internationale
face au danger
face à la peur
il tente de convaincre
les négociateurs
[Musique]
lundi 4 septembre 1972 Munich
les Jeux olympiques d'été ont commencé
depuis bientôt deux semaines et en
pleine période de guerre froide l'enjeu
est grand pour l'Allemagne
les organisateurs vous les saisir cette
chance pour montrer une nouvelle
Allemagne moderne dans l'air du temps
Pacifique
c'était un événement très important ils
accueillaient le monde entier
Charles Biétry est alors correspondant
de l'Agence France Presse il couvre la
compétition sportive
ça fait un peu cliché de parler de de la
trêve olympique de parler de la paix de
parler des branches d'olivier de parler
des colombes qu'on lançait le premier
jour des jeux ça fait un peu cliché mais
c'était ça c'était ça les Jeux
Olympiques
les Jeux Olympiques c'est un événement
mais c'est aussi un village dans la
ville
plus de 7000 athlètes du monde entier
cohabitent pour le sport et dans la fête
un village olympique c'est presque comme
un village de vacance vous avez des
bungalows là c'était des petits
immeubles blancs ils sont les uns à côté
des autres et puis les délégations
vivent
chacune règle générale dans un petit
immeuble
[Musique]
dans le village olympique il se passait
plein de choses il y avait des films
tous les soirs on dansait c'était
merveilleux
[Musique]
si tout est fait pour envoyer une image
de faite c'est parce que l'Allemagne a
des choses à faire oublier
la dernière fois que le pays a accueilli
les Jeux c'était en 1936 sous le régime
nazi avec Hitler aux commandes
c'était une Allemagne différente très
différente et il souhaitait que les gens
se rendent compte que ce passé était
loin derrière
en 1972 Anne-So Annecy n'est agent de
police dans la ville son équipement lui
interdit d'entrer dans le périmètre
en tant qu'agent armé nous n'avions pas
le droit d'entrer dans la zone olympique
cela nous était interdit
Mathias dalqueux est chercheur il s'est
spécialisé dans l'histoire très
particulière de ces Jeux Olympiques
on voulait à tout prix éviter que l'on
voit des uniformes des armes
qu'il dit une quelconque forme de
souvenirs ou de référence
aux JO de 1936
celle des 14 athlètes israéliens
pour eux venir en Allemagne est une
façon de montrer qu'ils adaptent au
Projet de paix olympique par de la
l'histoire
on l'avait vu lors du défilé de
d'ouverture que la délégation
israélienne avait été beaucoup applaudi
ce qui avait fait un peu chaud au cœur
et c'est vrai qu'on avait eu tous un œil
un petit peu
attendri sur cette délégation
l'entraîneur d'escrime de l'équipe
israélienne
en 1972 ils sont mariés depuis un an
elle vient de donner naissance à une
petite fille
André croyait fermement à l'idéal
olympique ce n'était pas facile pour eux
mais il voulait être là la tête haute
pour faire partie de cette grande fête
olympique
mardi 5 septembre minuit
pour la délégation israélienne la
journée se termine dans la bonne humeur
ils sont allés dans Munich pour voir une
comédie musicale tous ensemble puis
ensuite ils sont rentrés ensuite j'ai
parlé à André vers minuit je savais
qu'il était bien arrivé donc je suis
allé me coucher
au 31 connolish Traceux où se trouvent
les appartements de la délégation les
sportifs tombent dans un profond sommeil
avant les compétitions du lendemain
quelques heures plus tard leur destin va
basculer comme celui des Jeux Olympiques
tout entier
4h10 la nuit semble tranquille au
village olympique quand soudain un
groupe de 8 hommes arrive au niveau de
la porte 25A bordant le village
olympique
les portes sont fermées ils escaladent
les grilles aider par plusieurs sportifs
et qui rentrait au village et qui était
des athlètes comme eux
pourtant ces huit hommes ne sont pas des
champions
ils ont des joggings des sacs de sport
mais ce ne sont pas des équipements dans
les sacs mais des kalachnikov des
grenades des couteaux
des terroristes déguisés en sportif
ils ont une cible bien déterminée
il se rendent au 31 konolijs parce
qu'ils savent que les Israéliens y sont
hébergés
Marouane Mery et Laurent Combalbert sont
négociateur professionnel ils
analyseront toutes les étapes de la
crise à venir on comprend une chose
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de place à
l'improvisation ils connaissent
l'endroit exact du bâtiment ils ont un
passe également pour pouvoir rentrer
4h15 les terroristes entre groupés dans
le bâtiment en silence un homme reste à
la porte pour surveiller l'entrée la clé
de cette opération pour les terroristes
c'est l'effet de surprise ils vont
devoir capturer les athlètes pendant
leur sommeil ils vont devoir les figer
dans un état de sidération le plus vite
possible pour éviter une riposte ou pour
éviter que ils viennent à s'échapper
mais à l'intérieur de l'appartement un
des athlètes est alerté par les bruits
dans le couloir
le juge israélien good Freud était un
homme très imposant il ouvre la porte de
l'appartement et soudainement il voit
toutes les kalachnikov pointé sur lui
donc il cherche à pousser la porte avec
le poids de son corps et il crie aux
autres israéliens terroristes terroriste
l'alerte permet à certains athlètes de
s'échapper par la fenêtre mais la
résistance du coach ne dure pas
longtemps et les assaillants parviennent
rapidement à entrer dans l'appartement
Moshi va imberg un des sportifs cherche
à se rebeller avant d'être atteint par
une balle au visage son corps est jeté
devant le bâtiment
les assaillants poursuivent l'opération
il rabattent l'ensemble des sportifs au
premier étage l'un d'eux Joseph Romano
cherche aussi à résister il est abattu
son corps est laissé au sol
dans une chambre les assaillants ont
donc réunis 10 sportifs israéliens dont
un est déjà mort
aucune chance ne leur est laissée pour
s'échapper pour l'instant on fait de
l'action leur préoccupation c'est de
d'attacher les
otages entre eux de les ligoter de faire
en sorte que les otages de leur posent
pas de problème d'assurer la sécurité de
l'immeuble et de l'appartement en
faisant en sorte que les différents
terroristes couvrent les zones d'accès
ne soit pas surpris par la police cette
action d'écrasement elle est importante
parce que les terroristes sont moins
nombreux que les otages mais ils doivent
dès le début montrer qu'il contrôle
qu'il maîtrise
l'attaque ne reste pas inaperçue au
cours d'une patrouille un agent de
sécurité du village olympique surprend
brusquement la silhouette d'un des
assaillants
il donne immédiatement l'alerte
à 5h30
le commissaire de police de Munich
arrive dans le village olympique
il s'appelle Manfred Schreiber
à la nouvelle d'intrus armée au cœur du
site olympique l'homme à la réputation
bien trempé réalise la gravité de la
situation
manifeste
de la police de Munich
on l'appelait le chérif de Munich
son rôle était surtout de s'occuper du
bon ordre des questions de stationnement
et des petits problèmes de ce type de la
petite criminalité
il s'occupait des affaires courantes
dans la ville de Munich
son premier ordre est clair établir un
périmètre de sécurité autour du bâtiment
où les intrus armés ont été vus
Christian Prouteau et le fondateur du
GIGN pour lui cette étape est
indispensable au début de toute
situation inconnue
la règle elle est simple c'est fixer la
crise donc évitez que elle déborde ou
qu'elle se déplace il faut limiter la
crise à l'endroit où elle se produit
grâce à la carte du village olympique
les autorités comprennent que la
délégation israélienne est visée
les représentants diplomatiques du pays
sont immédiatement avertis
5h45 alors que Manfred ryber vient
d'arriver une nouvelle glaçante lui
parvient pendant qu'il m'était en place
le cordon de sécurité un des agents à
retrouver encore au pied du bâtiment
mortellement touché d'une balle au
visage il a été jeté du balcon
il s'agit de l'athlète tué par les
terroristes au début de leur opération
c'est le corps de Moshi van Berg le
coach de lutte il est le premier à être
tué et mis devant le bâtiment
c'est grave parce que ça veut dire que
les gens armés qui seront rentrés dans
le building dans lequel se trouvent les
têtes israéliens sont venus pour quelque
chose de très sérieux sont pris au
passage à l'acte si vous intervenez
les autres subiront le même sort
est impuissant
ils sont ces assaillants que veulent-ils
les deux athlètes israéliens échappés au
début de l'opération livre des premiers
éléments de réponse
il y aurait 10 otages à l'intérieur
les terroristes seraient armés mais
impossible en revanche de connaître leur
nombre
[Musique]
à 6 heures les policiers trouvent deux
feuillets tapés à la machine jeter
depuis le balcon du bâtiment
en bas de ses papiers une signature
Septembre noir
Septembre noir est une organisation de
combattants palestiniens l'année
précédente ces terroriste avait déjà
réalisé quelques actions spectaculaires
répartie dans toute l'Europe et très
bien connectée
on efface au plus radical ça on le sait
tout de suite le basculement vers le
l'acte politique il est fait il est fait
ça y est
les revendications sont précises une
liste de 236 personnels libérés au plus
vite
il voulait faire libérer des gens de
l'opposition palestinienne qui était
retenu dans les prisons israéliennes
l'ultimatum est fixé à 9h du matin
sans quoi chaque demi-heure ou chaque
heure un otage sera exécuté
l'ultimatum va être l'élément
structurant de la négociation à ce stade
de l'opération pourquoi parce que
d'abord c'est une menace il menace forte
de tuer les otages c'est une menace qui
est limitée dans le temps avec en tant
que relativement court puisqu'on est
censé pouvoir libérer 236 prisonniers
politiques en quelques heures
aussi professionnel soit-il le chef de
la police locale est un puissant face à
une situation d'ampleur diplomatique
bien sûr il y a des plans de crise
depuis plusieurs années l'Allemagne a
déjà connu des attentats à la bombe mais
une prise de tâches avec des
revendications politiques ça c'est tout
à fait nouveau
7 heures la prise d'otage a lieu depuis
plus de deux heures et demie
les terroristes ont vu les choses en
grand
[Musique]
depuis le Moyen-Orient ils ont
simultanément diffusé un véritable
communiqué de presse à toutes les
grandes rédactions
[Musique]
nos forces révolutionnaires ont pénétré
en force dans le pavillon israélien aux
Jeux Olympiques de Munich pour obtenir
que les autorités militaires
israéliennes adoptent une position plus
humaine à l'égard du peuple palestinien
l'information ne tarde pas à faire le
tour du monde avec 2000 équipes de
télévision présente pour les JO le
pavillon israélien est rapidement cerné
de journalistes
la situation est encore très confuse et
personne ne peut actuellement approcher
le bâtiment israélien isolé par la
police la nouvelle s'est répandue comme
une traînée de poudre les Palestiniens
menaces de les fusiller si 200
prisonniers politiques ne sont pas
libérés en Israël
Barry Davis est alors journaliste
sportif pour la BBC
je me souviens très bien j'avais un
point de vue sur ce bâtiment gris ou
rien ne se passait
on se met là on regarde on ne quitte
plus des yeux le bâtiment pour essayer
de saisir une info pour essayer de
comprendre
cette présence massive de journalistes
est au cœur de la stratégie des
terroristes de Septembre noir
manière dont cette prise de tâche a été
effectuée elle est pas simplement le
fait de faire une agression dans le
cadre des Jeux olympiques mais elle
était surtout de fixer l'attention du
monde sur le problème palestinien
cherchent une reconnaissance médiatique
ils ont déjà gagné on ne parlait plus
que de ça
7h15 la prise d'otage a lieu depuis
trois heures
pour gérer la situation une cellule de
crise est installée dans une tour située
à l'est du village olympique
en 1972 la cellule de crise qu'on peut
imaginer et pas du tout celle qu'on
ferait aujourd'hui on est dans
l'empirisme donc une cellule de crise
c'est une réunion autour d'une table des
gens qui ont l'autorité pour agir
autour de la table Manfred ryber et son
équipe mais aussi
le ministre de l'Intérieur d'Allemagne
fédérale
leur première initiative et de
s'entretenir avec Golda mère première
ministre d'Israël depuis les premières
heures elle suit l'avancée de la
situation elle seule peut répondre aux
attentes des terroristes rond dans un
problème géopolitique
très important les autorités allemandes
à ce stade sont dans l'expectative qui
vont devoir attendre que goldam hair qui
est le premier ministre israélien décide
ou pas si elle libère des prisonniers
ils ont fait les autorités allemandes ne
peuvent pas faire grand-chose pour
négocier sinon récupérer le maximum
d'informations savoir ce qu'il se passe
dans le bâtiment et trouver des idées
pour résoudre ce problème
les Allemands arrivent à une première
conclusion ils doivent gagner du temps
sans savoir comment s'y prendre
ce sont les balbutissements de la
négociation c'est très embryonnaire
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'équipe de
négociateurs qui sont constitués il n'y
a pas non plus d'organisation tactique
il n'est pas non plus d'expérience sur
ce type de situation c'était la
préparation la plus totale
l'ultimatum est pour 9h il leur reste
moins de deux heures pour trouver une
solution
7h30 depuis le début de la taque rien ne
laisse transparaître la situation à
l'intérieur du bâtiment lorsque soudain
au balcon du premier étage un homme sort
cagoule sur la tête
la première fois qu'un terroriste se
montre l'image est saisissante et fait
le tour des télévisions
c'est une image qui m'a hantée pendant
des années
Carlo tout sort est alors journaliste
pour le sud deg il a les yeux rivés sur
cet apparition
c'était comme au théâtre
on voyait des gens sur scène sans
vraiment réaliser que c'était la réalité
[Musique]
c'est un homme au balcon avec le visage
couvert du nez à la bouche
il est là et il observe ce qu'il se
passe à
l'entoureuse
on se rend rapidement compte qu'ils sont
assez détendus expérimentés
ils ont des chapeaux des masques sur le
visage et des lunettes
ces premières observations permettent de
tirer des informations précieuses sur le
profil des terroristes
ce qui est très intéressant c'est qu'ils
vont tous masquer leur visage
aucun ne souhaite être reconnu et ça
c'est un bon signe dans une négociation
parce que un terroriste qui ne veut pas
être reconnu ça veut dire qu'il anticipe
que il va se passer quelque chose après
il va pas forcément rester là pour
laisser ça sa vie dans le dans la
balance pour mourir dans l'opération et
ça c'est plutôt un bon signe
8h10 la prise d'otage a commencé il y a
presque 4 heures une policière habillée
en civile se présente devant le bâtiment
son objectif comprendre qui est le chef
des terroristes
à peine est-elle arrivée qu'un homme
sort cirage sur le visage et chapeau
colonial vissé sur la tête
et ça en tout cas c'est comme ça qu'il
se présente dit qu'il est le chef de ces
terroristes
apparemment on parle à celui qui
contrôle c'est au moins comme ça qui se
présente il est calme il est posé il est
grimé il a du cirage sur le visage et
surtout il parle allemand couramment
donc il a été clairement choisi pour
cette opération pour mener le commando
et également mener la négociation porter
les revendications
voici le contenu de leurs échanges
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tout cela veut dire cela
n'a rien à voir avec vous ou avec
l'Allemagne nous ne pouvons rien faire
pour libérer tous ces prisonniers
politiques en Israël nous ne pouvons que
leur transmettre vos conditions
vont mourir
on s'aperçoit qu'on peut parler avec le
chef des terroristes mais que ces
positions sont très claires et arrêtées
maintenant que la prise de contact a eu
lieu les autorités vont chercher à
différer l'ultimatum de façon
complètement improvisée
8h45 la prise d'otage a commencé depuis
près de 4h30
Manfred ryber et le reste des autorités
allemandes n'ont toujours aucune
nouvelle de la première ministre
d'Israël golden amer
elle est pourtant la seule à pouvoir
répondre aux exigences des terroristes
il ne leur reste que 15 minutes avant
que l'ultimatum n'arrive à son terme à
ce moment-là l'atmosphère devient
pesante mais physiquement moi j'ai
l'impression que j'ai des que j'ai
quelque chose de lourd qui se met sur
mes épaules et sur moi
chaque ultimatum vous avez un peu plus
l'impression de mourir ils en ont déjà
tué un et jeter son corps et je me dis à
ce moment-là qu'il n'hésiteront pas à
tuer un autre israélien
cette fois-ci ce n'est plus la femme au
costume bleu qui se rend au contact des
terroristes mais le chef de la police de
Munich lui-même accompagnée de la
cellule de crise une stratégie qui
apparaît aujourd'hui comme une erreur en
négociation
les Allemands ont envie de montrer leur
engagement leur détermination on met les
décideurs au contact des terroristes
c'est un petit problème en négociation
parce que dès lors que le décideur
rentre au contact il tombe à vision
tactique la prise de décision nécessite
une vision stratégique avec du recul
pour garder la tête froide et la vision
globale
en étant directement impliqué dans la
négociation les responsables pourraient
manquer de distance critique sur la
situation
les négociations vont avoir lieu dans la
rue face à l'entrée du bâtiment
c'était une partie de la stratégie des
terroristes
mener les négociations devant le
bâtiment comme sa personne ne pouvait
savoir ce qu'il se passait à l'intérieur
ce type de face à face je les connais et
je peux vous dire que c'est très tendu
vous savez que la manière dont vous vous
comportez peut être déterminant dans la
réaction de celui qui est en face de
vous c'est un équilibre fragile il faut
être crédible
on ne connaît pas la teneur des échanges
on en connaît l'enjeu différent
le chef de la police affirme avoir
besoin de plus de temps pour obtenir la
libération des prisonniers par Israël
[Musique]
Issa accepte immédiatement
si sa réaction peut sembler surprenante
pour Eric délaissé spécialiste des
questions de renseignements elle est
surtout le signe que le chef des
terroristes connaît les règles de la
négociation les terroristes ont atterri
dès le début à mettre la pression et
puis ils vont relâcher un tout petit peu
le l'accord de sur le coup des autorités
allemandes ils vont rester le maître du
jeu dans cette négociation c'est une
information capitale et structurante en
négociation à partir du moment où
l'ultimatum est repoussé on comprend
l'ultimatum est un moyen et non pas une
finalité ils ont affiché une liste de
236 prisonniers politiques mais ils sont
prêts à repousser l'ultimatum parce
qu'il bénéficient d'une couverture
médiatique internationale et cette
couverture médiatique est bien elle va
être donnée par le temps par la durée de
la prise d'otage les Allemands pensent
avoir gagné cette manche un nouvel
ultimatum est fixé à midi
il leur reste à présent 3 heures pour
trouver une nouvelle solution
9 heures la prise d'otage a commencé
depuis bientôt 5 heures
pourtant dans le village olympique les
jeux se poursuivent
[Applaudissements]
un petit moment de flottement
et puis les jeux vont continuer d'un
côté on essayait de maintenir l'image de
jeu Pacifique et de l'autre côté on
essayait de résoudre cette prise de
tâches sanglante
au centre de commandement toujours
aucune nouvelle de la première ministre
d'Israël Golda mère
Schreiber et le reste de l'équipe ne
voit pas d'issue possible
la cellule de crise était dans l'impasse
il n'avait pas d'information il n'avait
pas de signal positif de la part
d'Israël il ne pouvait rien faire sinon
espérer que l'ultimatum soit différé et
qu'une autre bonne idée soit proposée
à 10h le chef de la police a une idée
fort de son expérience du terrain il
propose aux terroristes d'échanger les
otages contre de l'argent
malheureusement la réponse est négative
c'est une véritable erreur que de
proposer de l'argent à des combattants
une rançon ce ne sont pas des criminels
ce sont des terroristes politiques et en
leur proposant de l'argent on va avilir
la situation qui sont en train de monter
on va nier leur revendications initiale
et ça c'est cette source de crispation
source de tension parce que le
terroriste peut imaginer qu'on a pas
compris son souhait réel
un souhait réel qui pour leur ne peut
être réalisé faute réponse côté
israélien alors à 10h30 les négociateurs
avancent un autre deal s'échanger
eux-mêmes contre les otages ou avouer
que avec du recul cette proposition des
autorites Allemands des quand même très
très surprenante c'est effectivement
quelque chose qu'on fait pas on le fait
pas parce que d'abord on a besoin
d'avoir les chefs hors de la situation
de prise d'otage évidemment mais en
l'occurrence ils sont certainement un
peu perdus ils ont pas grand chose à
donner mais ça va être également refusé
par Paris a
11h15 la prise d'otage a commencé depuis
7 heures
la première ministre israélienne Golda
meilleur répond enfin
bien corrigé de voir des Juifs à nouveau
persécutés sur le sol allemand son refus
de négocier et catégorie
c'est la douche froide pour les
Allemands parce qu'ils comprennent que
leur marge de manœuvre est extrêmement
limitée puisqu'à partir du moment où on
peut pas libérer les otages il va
falloir gérer les preneurs d'otages
petit à petit on est dans un entonnoir
qui pousse à une situation qui va être
de toute façon dramatique
il ne reste que 5 minutes avant
l'ultimatum
j'ai l'impression de mourir je me dis
vont-ils les tuer à présent
quand soudain Manfred ryber le chef de
la police de Munich apparaît sur les
écrans de télévision
une nouvelle fois il se rendent au
contact du chef des terroristes
son plan est radical
mon tiraïssa en lui affirmant qu'Israël
organise la libération des prisonniers
palestiniens et qu'ils ont besoin de
plus de temps
le recours maintenant pour les Allemands
ça va être d'utiliser le bluff le
mensonge parce qu'il se dit si on ne
peut rien proposer au terroriste le
risque c'est qu'ils abattent les otages
donc ils vont utiliser une cartouche qui
est très très risqué
ça ça fonctionne si l'assaut est prêt à
être déclenchée alors il y a pas de
groupe d'intervention il y a pas de
police spécialisé personne ne sait faire
ce genre d'assaut et donc là on est en
train de lancer une improvisation qui va
s'enchaîner minutes après minutes
une nouvelle limite à 17h mais les
négociateurs le savent puisqu'il sera
elle refuse de répondre aux
revendications des preneurs d'otages il
ne leur reste en réalité qu'une solution
l'attaque
seulement pour l'envisager encore
faut-il connaître le nombre de
terroristes présents dans le bâtiment
les autorités allemandes sont dans une
situation qui est quand même
épouvantable il faut le dire à l'époque
on ne dispose pas de moyens techniques
pour voir à travers les vitres fermées
et avec les rideaux tirés on dispose pas
de micro caméra que l'on peut introduire
à travers un mur on a pas les systèmes
d'imagerie radar qui voit à travers les
cloisons donc en réalité ils sont sous
et aveugle par rapport au nombre de
terroristes par rapport au nombre
d'armes qu'utilisateurs par rapport au
fait de savoir combien il reste de ta
janvier est-ce que certains sont blessés
ou est-ce qu'il se situe dans les pièces
c'était le problème majeur on voyait
toujours un ou deux terroristes devant
le bâtiment mais on avait aucune
information à propos des otages
on ne pouvait rien savoir sur eux ni sur
tout ce qui pouvait se dérouler dans le
bâtiment
derrière les murs de l'édifice les 9
athlètes sont tenus captifs dans une
chambre située au deuxième étage
le corps de Joseph Romano le sportif tué
au début de l'opération est toujours au
sol
ils étaient assis là toute la journée
les pieds et les mains attachés à la
table et au lit les uns aux autres ils
étaient au sol assis à attendre
en sous-vêtement puisqu'ils avaient été
tirés du lit
les huit terroristes ont mis au point un
système bien huilé d'abord les gardes
les gardes vont rester au sein de la
pièce où se trouvent les otages et leur
travail c'est de maîtriser toute
tentative d'évasion le système sécurité
est primordial pour eux pour s'assurer
du contrôle des otages pour s'assurer
qu'il ne s'échappe pas ou qui cherchent
à se rebeller on a ensuite ce qu'on
appelle les veilleurs les veilleurs eux
vont se positionner autour et vont
regarder ce qui se passe à l'extérieur
voir s'il y a une agitation particulière
mais surtout anticiper une opération de
la police prévenir voire même riposter
en cas de tentative d'intrusion par un
agent de sécurité ou par un policier
ces éléments personne à l'extérieur ne
les connaît
à 16h le chef de la police Schreiber
demande à Issa une preuve que les otages
sont vivants afin de poursuivre les
négociations
c'est toujours dans ce jeu du chat et
les souris qui se déroulent dans le
cadre d'une négociation ou ok nous on
fait un pas en avant vous voulez savoir
combien il y a d'otages on va vous le
dire regardez on les a pas tous tués
c'est d'une façon spectaculaire et très
médiatique que les terroristes apportent
la réponse
je regarde la télévision et soudain les
rideaux s'écartent la fenêtre s'ouvre et
voilà Andrée je le vois attachée avec
les mains dans le dos il est en maillot
de corps il se tient au deuxième étage
et il parle
ça montre qu'ils sont vivants qui sont a
priori en bonne santé et que donc la
monnaie des changes un échange des
prisonniers politiques elle existe elle
est toujours là on lui demande où en est
la situation avec les otages et André
dit tout le monde est OK sauf un
les négociateurs veulent connaître son
identité mais la conversation est
brusquement interrompue
il reçoit un coup de cross il est tiré
en arrière dans la chambre les rideaux
et la fenêtre se referment
si les terroristes interrompent
brutalement la conversation c'est pour
une raison très précise
si l'otage devait communiquer le nombre
de blessés le nombre de morts
l'organisation tactique des terrorisme
où il se trouve exactement sur les lieux
forcément il s'appellerait énormément de
pouvoir donc pour éviter une perte de
contrôle de la situation il décide de
clôturer ce round de négociation
il y a la manière de montrer que vous
êtes jusqu'au-boutiste et que vous êtes
prêt à aller jusqu'au bout et qu'il faut
pas rigoler une nouvelle fois
l'opération est un échec mais le chef de
la police pense avoir un plan il est sur
le point de lancer une opération à la
surprise générale
cela fait plus de 12 heures que la prise
d'otage a commencé quand soudain
Schreiber donne l'ordre d'une attaque
nom de code opération zone Einstein
l'objectif est de faire descendre une
équipe par les conduits d'aération
situés sur le toit du bâtiment le
problème c'est qu'à l'époque il n'existe
pas de commando en Allemagne pour mener
ce type d'action
ce sont donc des policiers municipaux
comme einson qui sont à la manœuvre
ils sont déguisés en survêtement de
sport pour se faire passer pour des
athlètes
nous étions une équipe d'une douzaine de
volontaires
on nous avait distribué des survêtements
de sport et des casques de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale
on est dans l'improvisation totale il y
a pas de groupe d'intervention il y a
même pas l'idée de ce qu'il faudrait
faire pour organiser un plan tactique
pour gérer ce type de ce type de cas
donc c'est là la cacophonie qu'on peut
percevoir entre les survêtements d'un
côté les armes de l'autre des policiers
qui se dispersent
il s'agit d'officier de police qui
s'occupe de la circulation à Munich et
ils sont censés éliminer les terroristes
[Musique]
il n'y avait pas vraiment de stratégie
d'intervention
l'opération se déroule sous l'objectif
des caméras ce que les autorités
ignorent c'est que les terroristes
peuvent aussi en être témoins ils
disposent d'une télévision dans la
chambre
le monde entier peut voir ses policiers
en train d'essayer de rentrer dans le
bâtiment mais les terroristes eux-mêmes
peuvent les voir
ces images ont fait le tour du monde et
on en parle encore aujourd'hui
on va voir en direct l'ensemble de ces
hommes se positionner sur le toit du
bâtiment où se trouve les athlètes
prisonnotages mais également se
disperser autour de ce bâtiment c'est
une image et horissante hallucinante
même
nous attendions que notre chef
donne le nom de code zone
pour pouvoir lancer l'assaut et libérer
les otages
au même moment les terroristes semblent
particulièrement agitées au balcon de
l'immeuble
il n'en faut pas plus aux autorités pour
comprendre que les preneurs d'otages
sont également spectateurs de la Seine
alors que l'ultimatum arrive à son terme
l'opération en zone Einstein est
immédiatement avortée
16h55 plus que 5 minutes avant que
l'ultimatum n'arrive à son terme
13h bientôt que les négociations ont
commencé sans qu'elle n'aboutissent
c'était un jour particulièrement tendu
chaque heure était pierre chaque heure
on se rendait compte qu'il n'y aurait
pas de solutions
[Musique]
et là on commençait à se poser des
questions
qu'est-ce qui va se passer
contre toute attente la solution va
venir des terroristes dans la cellule de
crise Schreiber décroche le téléphone et
c'est Issa au bout du fil
ça demande à radicalement changer il
demande un avion pour partir avec le
reste des otages en direction de
l'Egypte dans la négociation c'est un
tournant capital là apparemment on parle
plus des prisonniers libérés on parle de
leur départ
on comprend qu'ils ne sont pas prêts à
mourir pour leurs causes donc c'est très
intéressant ils veulent maintenant
simplement s'échapper donc ce ne sont
pas des jusqu'au-boutistes
ça nous permet de comprendre une chose
c'est que avec la position qu'ils
affichaient la libération des
prisonniers politiques n'était pas
forcément leur véritable enjeu leur
véritable enjeu c'était la
reconnaissance médiatique
les autorités acceptent l'offre sans
hésiter car pour eux c'est l'occasion
d'un chantage ils affrêteront bien un
avion pour les terroristes à condition
de pouvoir eux-mêmes entrer dans le
bâtiment afin de s'assurer de l'état de
santé des otages
et ça se plie à cette condition pour la
première fois de la journée les
Allemands vont pouvoir recueillir des
informations c'était un moment unique
puisqu'ils vont rentrer au cœur du siège
là maintenant on va observer observer
tout ce qui est possible les personnes
qui vont rentrer à l'intérieur vont
compter les terroristes vont décrire
leurs vêtements vont regarder leurs
armements vont observer leurs attitudes
et essayer de comprendre s'il y a des
subalters netsia des chefs d'équipe par
exemple les négociateurs s'adressent
également aux otages
ils ont demandé à chacun s'il avait un
message
André a dit qu'il espérait que tout le
monde soit bientôt libéré
qu'il nous aimait moi et notre fille à
nous
et qu'il espérait que nous soyons
bientôt ensemble à la maison
pour les Allemands c'est aussi une
chance inespérée de compter le nombre de
terroristes
les témoins oculaires avaient compté en
tout et pour tous cinq terroristes
à éliminer
le chiffre est immédiatement communiqué
aux autorités une opération est montée
se basant entièrement sur cette
information
les terroristes sont en réalité bien
plus nombreux
18 heures
dans la cellule de crise presque 14
heures depuis le début de la prise
d'otage
pour la première fois Schreiber et son
équipe retrouvent confiance
cette demande est terroriste est une
occasion de reprendre la main ce
changement de configuration est très
intéressante pour les pour les autorités
allemandes elles croient qu'elles ont
suffisamment d'informations elles ont un
nombre de terroristes elles savent
combien ils restent d'otages
[Musique]
à ce stade on a une occasion qui ne
s'est pas encore présentée c'est-à-dire
une des premières fois ils ont le
pouvoir de faire quelque chose et de
donner satisfaction au point dans
l'otage un plan se dessine un piège
tendu au terroriste avec pour théâtre la
base militaire de furstenfelbruck situé
à une quarantaine de kilomètres à
l'ouest de la
il décide de prendre Bruck parce que
c'est un aéroport militaire
tout pousser à ce que le choix se porte
sur firsteinfelbruck
les Allemands maîtrisent parfaitement la
configuration de cet aéroport éloigné
des regards indiscrets par toute une
série de clôtures de sécurité l'idée d'y
faire venir les terroristes en
hélicoptère depuis Munich et de placer
sur le tarmac en Boeing 727 pour faire
croire à leur départ imminent
5 tireurs d'élite les viseront au moment
opportun au centre du dispositif un
bâtiment pourra accueillir la cellule de
crise allemande
Haral de Meyer est alors élève pilote
sur cette base militaire
c'est une tour avec une vue imprenable
vers le nord ou les deux hélicoptères
allaient être parqués
et de l'autre côté en tournant la tête à
90 degrés il y avait une vue parfaite
sur le Boeing 727 et puis au-dessus une
tourelle
l'opération repose sur un piège tendu au
terroriste à l'intérieur du Boeing 727
16 policiers y sont en fait déguisés en
membre d'équipage
ce qui était organisé c'est que nous
soyons prêts
c'est de faire monter le chef du
commando et éventuellement son adjoint
dans l'avion pour aller vérifier que
l'avion est opérationnel qui a un pilote
aux commandes et qu'on peut partir les
policiers déguisés en Stewart ont pour
mission de neutraliser la tête du
commando et on pense qu'en sortant Issa
du jeu et bien on va désorganiser le
commandant
il y a une diversion qui déclenche
l'opération et la vitesse d'exécution
et la garantie de libération des otages
la nuit tombe sur Munich
négociateur et terroristes pensent que
le dénouement est proche personne ne
s'attend en réalité au tour que vont
prendre les événements
22h presque 18h depuis le début de la
prise d'otage
un minibus se gare face au parking
souterrain de l'immeuble de la
délégation israélienne
[Musique]
Issa et le reste des terroristes
s'engouffre dans le véhicule
accompagner des otages
monte dans les bus c'est là ça permet de
compter combien il y a de personnes et
de voir que les terroristes sont 8
personnes retransmet l'information
au sniper qui se sont positionnés pour
réceptionner cinq terroristes
le minibus parcourt quelques centaines
de mètres avant que les terroristes et
leurs otages ne s'engouffrent dans les
hélicoptères
il est 22h05 quand il décolle en
direction de l'aéroport de
firstenfelbruck
sur la base militaire le plan des
autorités ne va pas du tout se passer
comme prévu
à l'aéroport les équipes apprennent que
les hélicoptères sont en route dans la
tour de contrôle l'ensemble de la
cellule de crise est en place mais
brusquement alors que les terroristes
sont sur le point d'arrivée les
policiers déguisés en Stewart dans
l'avion sont pris de panique hein fait
partie de ceux mobilisés sur cette
opération
je me suis fermement opposé à cette
intervention
l'appareil était plein d'essence
et les terroristes disposaient de
grenades
cela aurait été la mort assurée il
décide de voter à main levée et ils vont
tous lever la main en considérant qu'ils
ne sont pas prêts pour ce type de
mission ils sont descendus de l'avion
ils sont partis le plan entier est tombé
à l'eau à ce moment là
22h30 les deux hélicoptères arrivent
au-dessus du tarmac de firstenfelbruck
autorité et tireur retiennent leur
souffle
à peine arrivé
Issa accompagné d'un autre terroriste se
dirige vers l'avion pour s'assurer qu'il
est prêt au départ
deux des terroristes dont le chef entre
dans le Boeing 727 par l'arrière
traverse le fuselage vers le cockpit et
là il voit qu'il n'y a personne
à s'apercevoir que apparemment on lui a
entendu un piège que l'avion est vide il
va descendre précipitamment de l'avion
pour rejoindre les hélicoptères et
rejoindre ses complices au moment de
l'opération
énigmeers est alors élève officier dans
un bâtiment proche du tarmac
au même moment j'entends une voix venant
de la tour de contrôle
qu'est-ce que vous attendez tirez tirez
maintenant et à ce moment précis un
échange de tir complètement incontrôlé a
commencé tout le monde a commencé à
tirer
on va voir bien sûr à ce moment-là ce
qu'on appelle la loi de Murphy c'est que
tout ce qui pouvait tourner mal à mal
tourner et là c'est le carnage complet
nombreux personne n'était préparé à ce
scénario personne
les tireurs allemands à la manoeuvre
sont loin d'être préparés à l'exercice
aucune coordination n'existe entre les
équipes
le problème est que les tireurs d'élite
n'ont pas de moyens de communication
entre eux ni de cibles définies
et savent pas sur qui va tirer le voisin
ils peuvent être en train de tirer sur
le même
à 22h45 alors que les tirs n'ont
commencé que depuis quelques minutes les
terroristes tirent sur les projecteurs
de l'aéroport
[Musique]
à ce stade on a des terroristes qui sont
dans les hélicoptères sur les otages les
otages sont attachés sur leur siège ils
ne peuvent pas s'enfuir ils peuvent pas
s'échapper on a des hélicoptères qui
sont plein de carburants des terroristes
qui sont équipés de grenades des
échanges de feu des tirs croisés très
certainement une énorme cacophonie c'est
un combat dans un tunnel ça c'est sûr on
ne sait plus sur quoi on tire
minuit les hélicoptères ont atterri
depuis 1h30 et l'opération est toujours
en cours une opération c'est
la surprise la flagrance crée la
sidération en face et obtenir la
neutralisation une opération ça dure
quelques secondes
les échanges de tir durent à peu près
deux heures trente
[Musique]
à l'extérieur des centaines de
journalistes sont devant les grilles de
la base militaire
personne ne sait ce qu'il se passe
depuis que les terroristes ont quitté le
site olympique
soudain il voit arriver en convoi de
voiture blindées qui s'engouffre dans la
zone militaire
les autorités veulent à présent lancer
un assaut pour éliminer les terroristes
la réaction des Palestiniens est
radicale
les terroristes voyant que la situation
leur échappe voyant également qu'ils
vont mourir vont tenter en fait le tout
pour le tout donc oui l'opération se
transforme en opération suicide c'est
une guerre il y a plus de négociation
possible
à minuit 4 l'un des terroristes tirent
dans l'habitacle de l'hélicoptère située
à l'Est avant d'y jeter une grenade il y
a une énorme explosion avec une traînée
bleue dans le ciel qui monte à 15 mètres
20 mètres
un terroriste exécute tous les captifs
présents dans l'autre hélicoptère
dans les minutes qui suivent l'opération
arrive à son terme 5 des terroristes
sont abattus 3 sont finalement capturés
par la police allemande tous les otages
israéliens ont finalement été tués 2 au
village olympique et les 9 autres à
l'aéroport
à l'extérieur pourtant contre toute
attente les premières nouvelles sont
excellentes
une dépêche de l'agence Reuters précise
que tous les otages israéliens sont
libérés
la radio allemande on commence à
entendre les champs en direct de Tel
Aviv d'Israël les chants de joie qui
fêtaient la libération des otages
on était heureux goldamère était heureux
tout le monde était fou de joie mon père
a sabré le champagne à la cacophonie
qu'on a pu observer dans la préparation
et la conduite de cette opération elle
se poursuit dans la communication
c'est-à-dire que une crise est terminée
que quand on a communiqué sur ce qui
s'est passé que les informations qu'on a
donné sont vraies et là en l'occurrence
on va communiquer très très vite avec ce
sentiment que c'est une réussite que
tous les otages sont vivants et que les
terroristes ont été neutralisés
plus tard dans la nuit l'annonce
officielle du drame sera finalement
faite plongeant le monde dans l'horreur
le 6 septembre au lendemain de la prise
d'otage c'est la consternation
il y a eu une grande cérémonie avec une
minute de silence on a essayé de rendre
hommage aux morts mais en même temps la
décision avait été prise de poursuivre
les jeux pour montrer qu'on ne se
laissait pas influencer
[Musique]
l'idée était qu'il fallait continuer
sinon ça aurait été une victoire pour
les terroristes
le reste de la délégation israélienne
quitte l'Allemagne dans la journée avec
la dépouille des otages pour Israël
c'est le début d'une opération nom de
code colère de Dieu une vendetta qui
durera près de 20 ans des commandos
israéliens traqueront et assassineront
des dizaines de personnes censées être
en lien avec la prise de tâches
quelle conclusion tirer sur cette
opération les négociateurs allemands
auraient-ils pu éviter le carnage
la difficulté sur Munich c'est qu'on a
agrégé le rôle de négociateur et de
décideurs ils ont perdu leur lucidité
leur capacité de vision objective
l'enjeu c'était la couverture médiatique
la position c'était les prisonniers
politiques quand on négocie sur une
position qui est irréaliste avec un
enjeu qu'on n'a pas perçu on ne peut pas
réussir une négociation
exalement ne seront pas restés vaines
Munich sera un électrochoc pour les
services de renseignement du monde
entier
c'est véritablement l'élément
déclencheur
pour la création des unités
antiterrorisme de dire que 90% viennent
là tout ce qui faut pas faire a été fait
c'est l'exemple qui était indispensable
pour se poser les vrais problématiques
comment faire pour pas faire la même
chose que les Allemands
c'est pour nous la jeunesse de notre
métier le métier de négociateur de crise
et de négociateur en groupe
d'intervention a été pensé après Munich
[Musique]